hey what's going on in happy holidays
hot ones fans its Sean Evans checking in
with a festive blazer and you know what
that means [ __ ] sometimes it's a little
redundant like you don't need to tell me
hey Sean you know could be a really good
guest on hot ones and I'm always like oh
whoo-hoo-hoo in my head I always know
here comes Gordon Ramsay you're gonna
bilberry are gonna burger Gordon Ramsay
you ever thought about it like yeah dude
it's it's been brought up a time or two
two years of my [ __ ] life been going
through this was that too heavy-handed
okay let me let me dial that one back a
little bit a little little under the
table
Santa's milk right there like that one
Honda hey what's going on and Happy
Holidays hot ones fans it's Sean Evans
checking in with the festive blazer and
you know what that means
it's time once again for our year-end
holiday spectacular next week we'll be
closing out the year with something very
special for you a chicken wing gauntlet
the likes of which have never been seen
before it's a hot ones so extreme so
reckless and borderline irresponsible
that we could only find one brave soul
to do something so stupid and it just
love the taste but today is all about
you guys the fans the ones who make this
all possible it's been so long since
we've had a real heart-to-heart so here
I am in a Santa hat to answer your
hard-hitting hot ones questions per
tradition can I get the stocking full of
questions Thank You Viking this first
one comes from Colin which interview
were you the most nervous for two
stories immediately stand out to me I
remember during the bryan cranston james
franko episode which was our season two
finale there was some bizarre situation
where bryan cranston had to be in some
remote town in the southwest and then
the last flight leaving out of New York
to get him there was running right up
against the interview so his handlers
were at the last second being like Oh
Bryan Cranston can't make the interview
can you do it was just James Franco but
as hot ones fans know there's tons of
behind the scenes work that goes into
making these shows in these interviews
so I had this Bryan Cranston James
Franco interview and then all of a
sudden it might be just James Franco
except I have questions for Bryan
Cranston and James Franco and that I'm
learning about this 15 minutes before
the cameras start rolling and then at
the last second there was a private jet
booked and everything snapped into place
and it was all fine but in the moments
leading up to that I just wanted a
sinkhole to swallow up the set and me
along with it another story that comes
up in my head when I think about it is
the Colbert show when I did that you
know it was kind of all coming to a head
because my dad was such a fan of David
Letterman so I felt like oh wow this is
such a big deal to do the biggest show
in late-night and to have hot ones and
wings and all this stuff coming together
my stomach's doing backflips and in my
head I'm like all right listen there are
like six shows on late-night they all
run through three guests this thing's
been going on for 50 years
what's one segment it's not that big a
[ __ ] deal Sean but it's one thing to
say that in your head it's quite another
when you're just standing there behind
the curtain and Colbert sends it to
commercial and you hear the band plane
and the Ed Sullivan Theater is packed
and you step on the stage you don't even
feel your feet hitting the ground and
the whole time it's just sort of
out-of-body experience and you just try
to get through the whole thing without
the engine running now without your
battery dying and without just
collapsing onstage so those are two
stories that stand up the next question
how do you research your guests it is
exactly what it looks like you just you
read your watch you listen to everything
that you possibly can me and Chris
Schaumburg are the show's creator we
chessgame this whole interview out
usually takes us hours and hours and
hours to crank that through after doing
hours and hours and hours and hours of
research but that's what it takes damn
it that's what it takes to keep the hot
ones boat afloat
how's
butthole proud to say doing great what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger and
I'd venture to say one of the strongest
most resilient titanium steel buttholes
around next question get on that one
all right into the mug of all the sauces
which is your favorite which is your
least favorite we're going all-time I
think that the worst sauce that we've
ever had on the show is pain 100 when it
comes to the best it's kind of a toss-up
for me I like the scotch bonnet and
ginger Queen Majesty that we have out
there dirty dicks is great big L Yucatec
oh god just depends on what I'm eating
all right what's one story regarding hot
ones that you've always wanted to tell
but haven't been given the suitable
opportunity - one that pops out to me is
with Rachael Ray now the good thing
about hot ones and the way that we've
been able to punch outside of her weight
class in a lot of ways is that we can
just pop this budget set up on whoever
wherever whenever so if a guest is like
oh I'm in LA boom we get on a flight
we'll pop this thing up in LA we'll pop
this thing up in your garage or in
Rachael Ray's case we'll pop this thing
up at your studio so I remember when I
rolled up there's a wraparound line of
tourists all these moms that are really
happy to go be in the live studio
audience at Rachael Ray so we pop up our
hot ones studio at Rachael Ray's spot
and she's gonna come in between her
morning filming and her afternoon
filming and she's like I got this how
hot can it be it's no big deal
and as you'll recall in that famous
spoon episode she's just mainlining
spoonfuls of hot sauce and by the end
was just knocking on death's door just
like a total mess boobs sweat a river
runs through it everyone knows the story
so I walk out there with my suitcase
full of hot sauces and as I'm walking
down I see this producer saying to this
entire group of people the afternoon
session for the Rachael Ray Show has
been cancelled we apologize for any
inconvenience and then there's just a
riot out on the street it's just torches
and pitchforks of all these Imams who
wanted to go to Rachael Ray we just
ruin their vacation just popping up hot
ones on him the best of times the worst
of times alright next from Mike Miller
how do you choose the guests that appear
in hot ones and does the comment section
of your videos serve to provide ideas
for potential upcoming guests you know a
lot of YouTube channels a lot of
youtubers they'll be like oh we're
family blah blah blah da da da
by the way 15% off t-shirts did it it
did it did it it you know but I think
that with hot ones there really is value
in having that real life focused group
at all times so you can see the way that
the comments section does inform and
shape the show but there are a lot of
moving parts and it really is a
situation where people are like grinding
behind the scenes all the time to ensure
that at 11:00 a.m. on Thursday there is
a fully produced hot ones episode and
that's been a pretty crazy grind I think
if there's one disconnect between the
show and the people who watch the show
or at least the people who complain in
the comments section is that it's not
easy to just get somebody to come on
your chicken wing YouTube show it's very
very difficult it's a mixture of like
knowing who your audience wants to see
which obviously we pay attention to and
then there's something with just timing
circumstances getting those things to
line up and then BAM getting someone in
the seat to agree to eat scorching hot
chicken wings on YouTube not an easy
sell what's been the biggest difference
from the first hot ones episode to now I
think that everything's changed if you
watch the first episode you know it's
only 7 wings the questions these goofy
questions we always thought that maybe
we'd be some sort of YouTube sideshow
little funny show but I would say thanks
to you guys for watching and pushing us
is the bar just keeps getting higher and
higher and higher and to run that flag
up the pole it just takes more and more
and more so the aspirations now have
completely transformed like to us now
we're trying to create this Lane where
we're just like the most interesting
best interview show and that's thanks to
you that is 1,000% the fans because we
know that if we don't jump that bar if
we don't just keep
leveling up that you're just not going
to accept it and you're gonna reject it
and then you're gonna go back to
watching fight comps on worldstar and we
don't want you like that one time I
goddamn I love when I can get it down
with most Awkward date experience one
time I had to dump a chick who was
actually a little out of my league and
it hurt at the time because it was clear
to everybody but she stole her
neighbor's cat and I just had to draw a
line on moral grounds and tell her like
it wasn't right and like I can't I just
can't talk to you anymore like I'm not
gonna not gonna snitch on you but you
can't just take your neighbor's cat and
then on top of that you know you're in a
high-rise like aren't you at all nervous
that you're gonna like go to work and
you're gonna open your door and your
neighbors gonna be like is that my cat
if you had my cat for months
we have lost signs up in the lobby every
day how could you steal my cat I just
couldn't be an accessory to that so I
had to dip and I think that would
qualify as awkward Shawn
why don't you call guests out for taking
baby bites or cancel out their plug if
they ducked the last death you know if I
was ever in a position where I was
hosting some chicken wing YouTube show
and I just opened it with like alright
Cara Delevingne
here are the rules there's a 2-byte
minimum you need to take from each bite
of the wing if you don't eat all the
last dab then we will be cancelling out
your plug and then I'm just doing this
sort of like YouTube chicken wing
challenge show that's not really what we
are what we're trying to do it's an
interview show the intended effect of
the hot sauce is to knock people off
their game there is no point system for
the people going at Brett Baker it's
just a completely made-up power ranking
that's just in Brett Baker's head you
know like you could just do the same
thing yourself if you want to do you
know like and call them out like what do
you want me to do look car you didn't
you didn't finish the zombie apocalypse
wing your plug is officially canceled
like it's not that serious it's not that
important and people are like well why
why is he introducing the gas in the
front of the show and talking about
their projects oh well like what do you
want me to do just be like oh like
here's Eric Andre and what he does is a
complete mystery no one will ever know
until he finishes the wings like you
have to set the table somehow like
here's Eric Andre he's on the Aragon
drew
chohee does this that the other thing
welcome to this show like you have to
set the table like what people do with
their plot like nobody I know I don't
have the energy for it anymore you know
four seasons hundred episodes like what
you want me to just like I had my
scorecard out we want to referee on
wings and stuff it's like it's not gonna
happen
and I apologize to some of you out there
who are like upset about that my bad you
know you can't be all things to all
people and I've come to accept that I
hope that you do too alright looking at
this stocking well there you have it
it's the bottom of the stocking thank
you so much if you submitted a question
I know that there were thousands more
online into the hot ones fans out there
you do not want to miss next week
special with chili Klaus it is nuts
it is berserk it's an afternoon that
I'll never forget
thank you so much for rockin with us
through season one through season two
through season three now through season
four and as is tradition we have our one
shining moment look back on the season
that was roll the tape hey what's going
on everybody four first we feast I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings first of all it was
very smooth yeah that was like the most
coolest intro I've ever been given or
the [ __ ] is the teleprompter this guy's
good yeah I'm scared I really want to
get to the last stab I'm very concerned
my ass is going to explode on cam and
that can send me screw it let's get some
wigs I feel like I'm gonna get in
trouble with the hospice community I
mean yeah they do they get fired up but
I mean what do you have to prove to the
hot sauce community that I have hot
sauce bowls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man
you I didn't sign up for this man I'm
never gonna forget this interview bro
this is like crazy whoa whoa whoa don't
call him he's eaten Oh No
cheyanne charm hell yeah you should hear
repeat the question yeah I did not but
Kevin Lord yeah it was me I can't really
talk right now because I'm doing this
thing called hot ones hey hey we say hot
ones where I keep like outrageously hot
[ __ ] while answering salacious
ill-advised question Winona Ryder
[Applause]
[Laughter]
gangster nobody's ever asked me anything
like that Wow
that's a great question yeah how do you
know then reading about you're smart
they say yo cop you better pay this man
hey you know yeah I'm feeling the rage
next one is dirty dicks very aggressive
brand name dirty what dirty dicks oh it
smells beautiful though it pause this is
the last dab we call it the last dab
because it's tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last wing you
don't have to if you don't want to but I
think it's a good time to mention that
Kevin Love did now what amigos holy [ __ ]
yeah how do people do that follow me to
cry I'm so hungry though what a [ __ ]
trip through the hot wing gauntlet you
came in you cleared the board you
dominated the wings look at you at the
top of the mountain and looking great
[Applause]
my next guest web show hot ones where he
interviews celebrities while they eat
ridiculously spicy chicken wings tonight
I answered the belly of the beast
ladies and gentlemen Sean Evans what
[ __ ] am i doing Jesus hello hot ones
fans it's Sean Evans new outro same
message if you like what just saw throw
us a bone maybe please it is dog-eat-dog
here on the YouTube streets hit that
subscribe button knowing that you
subscribed it is seriously the only
thing that gets me out of bed in the
morning
thank you very much hot ones fans I love
you